là je fais ce que je veux c'est ce qui
me plaît ce qui n'est pas le cas à
l'école luc à l'école ont obligés à
prendre quelque chose et tu restant
fermée toute la journée
[Musique]
oui je me sens différent parce qu'ils
ont
herisau pas du tout la même éducation
que moi et moi ça me gêne pas oui ils
ont leur éducation et j'ai la mienne
c'est de leur faire comprendre que je
moi aussi je peux apprendre des choses
et des choses et moi aussi j'ai je suis
pas de béquille reste enfermée chez moi
tout le temps et qu'il n'y apprend rien
[Musique]
fait assez peu de sport mais souvent
quand je vois des amis on va faire une
partie de basket où une partie de foot
voilà
et sinon je participe à plein d'ateliers
différents par exemple la gpl atelier la
chimie dans ses assiettes et ça consiste
en fait à faire de la chimie tout en
cuisinant en fait tu vas créer des
aliments tout en faisant de la chimie et
c'est super intéressant
[Musique]
au démarrage lorsque les enfants étaient
petits c'est moi qui faisais un petit
peu le programme de ce qu'on allait
faire donc sur les cinq jours ouvrés on
va dire de la semaine on était en
général 4 à l'extérieur on allait
beaucoup sur des expositions des musées
des ateliers ou parfois juste rencontrer
les autres familles dans un square pour
que les enfants jouent ensemble et aussi
leurs moments de récréation
[Musique]
c'est eux qui sont moteurs de leur
apprentissage
nous on est là pour fournir
l'environnement les questions vous
chercher ensemble les réponses en tout
cas aux questions et être l'adulte sur
qui on peut compter pour nous aider à
acquérir un certain une certaine
compétence etc
si nécessaire
[Musique]
je pense pas que il ya quelque chose qui
va me manquer je pense que juste les
gens s'ils veulent se raconter des
histoires de leurs de leur passé de
l'école tout ça je pense que j'aurai
aussi des anecdotes à raconter mais
totalement différente et ça peut être
aussi intéressant j'ai pas le stress que
beaucoup de gens quand c'est la fin du
week-end ou quand c'est la rentrée et
qu'il faut aller acheter les fournitures
scolaires j'ai mon propre emploi du
temps je peux me coucher me lever à
n'importe quelle heure maximum on va
quand même obligé de se coucher à 8
heures seulement 6 7 1 mais je peux
faire un peu ce que je
pour la grande majorité d'entre nous on
est tous convaincus qu'on fait du mieux
qu'on peut pour nos enfants
donc je ne juge pas et je ne jette pas
la pierre alors qu'on ne juge pas non
plus et qu'on ne me jette pas la pierre
non plus d'avoir fait un choix qui peut
paraître marginal il vous paraît avoue
marginal pour moi il ne l'est pas il est
juste l'expression naturelle de montr
sentier de l'amour inconditionnel que
j'ai pour mes enfants
si pour vous le choix que vous avez fait
il est important pour vous je pense que
vous pouvez prendre conscience qui est
important pour nous ce choix là aussi